there are some details that go by so
quickly in the final trailer for Todd
Phillips Joker you could hardly be
blamed for not noticing that while
others are subtlety manic touches that
speak to exactly what kind of Joker
we're dealing with here with that in
mind here's a look at some of the small
details you may have missed in the final
Joker trailer while Arthur's mother
penny is prominently featured in the
first Joker trailer we don't see her
much this time around she's only in a
couple of brief shots and her face is
covered when she appears but what's
happening to penny in the final trailer
may be the main catalyst that sparks
flecks transformation it appears as if
Arthur's mother is dying
what Arthur realizes talk-show hosts
Marie Franklin is on TV and talking
about him he's in his mother's hospital
room we briefly see penny in her bed on
the Wrights with a breathing apparatus
attached to her face possibly with the
breathing tube inserted if that's the
case then there's a good chance penny
Fleck isn't long for this world
her death if it happens could be enough
to finally push Arthur over the edge we
hear what king Phoenix is chilling Joker
cackle Ellie in the final trailer though
the circumstances surrounding it are
strange black is walking down a hallway
and an unknown building while buttoning
up a shirt considering the creepy clown
stuff in the background and the dressing
room lights similar to the ones seen in
the first trailer this is likely the
headquarters for his professional
clowning gig and he's just ended his
shift it's interesting because it's a
very Joker laughs but it's belted out in
a very non Joker way it seems like maybe
Fleck is laughing just to placate his
co-workers and that's why he stops as
soon as he's out of earshot it suggests
the Joker is something of a persona like
his slowly building something to protect
himself from social situations he's not
equipped to handle but what is initially
a ruse no more real than the makeup or
the clown costume he wears will soon
become his true self The Joker likes
kids or at least Arthur Fleck does
there's a brief shot toward the end of
the final trailer of blech clowning
around for kids in a hospital and early
in the trailer he's making faces to
entertain a boy on a Gotham City bus we
also see him trying to entertain the
young Bruce Wayne in the first Joker
trailer though it's possible he has an
ulterior motive for that since Bruce's
dad
Thomas Wayne is clearly his adversary
typically if the Joker has anything to
do with children at all he's being his
typical menacing self a Joker who seems
to
you enjoy entertaining kids is
intriguing though most of the
interactions we've seen this joker have
with children seem to be before his
transformation into the Clown Prince of
Crime it will be interesting to see if
his love for children survives in the
first Joker trailer we only see Thomas
Wayne on television this time we see
Arthur black and Wayne standing face to
face and the confrontation gets heated
just a joke to you we don't know what
Thomas is talking about but it's
possible the timing of the Wayne flek
confrontation and the trailer may
contain a clue right before we see Wayne
throw his punch we get two shots that
were also in the first trailer flecks
smashing his head against the metal mesh
barrier while grabbing for a file and
then running down a hallway looking as
if he's being chased still holding the
file
what file does flex steal it looks like
he's an Arkham State Hospital and he's
wearing the same outfit he wore while
walking across the street to the
hospital in the first trailer is it a
patient file belonging to someone close
to Thomas Wayne perhaps we've heard a
lot about comedian Marc Mara and getting
cast in Joker the news raised a few
eyebrows particularly because Maron has
been outspoken about his low opinion of
superhero movies the new trailer gives
us our first look at Maron as Ted Marco
and it's quick
he appears toward the end with Murray
and Fleck as the latter asked to be
introduced as Joker for a while it
wasn't completely clear exactly what
meirin's role and Joker would be but in
mid June 2019 while promoting sort of
trust he opened up about Marko saying I
basically played De Niro's producer in a
quick scene he added that his role isn't
very big but that the scene itself is
pivotal Marin went on to say that his
character is a guy trying to manage the
whole situation between Fleck and Murray
this could mean that Fleck hasn't
forgiven Murray for humiliating him as
we've seen earlier in the trailer and
that Ted Marcos there is a peacemaker
but considering that Murray made a fool
out of the clearly unhinged flag while
he was struggling with his mother's
illness
Marco likely won't succeed in his little
diplomatic endeavor toward the end of
the trailer we see a Mele on a subway
between the police and a bunch of
Joker's followers in the middle of it
Joker even though he's already in pole
clown makeup puts on one of his
followers clown masks possibly to
disguise himself if you thought this
looked familiar well it totally is this
sequence is reminiscent of Christopher
Nolan's The Dark Knight and Heath
Ledger's legendary Joker the first time
Ledger's Joker's on screen his back is
to us
he holds the clown mask he's about to
put on his part of the bank robbery at
the end of the opening scene we learned
that even though he's been wearing a
clown mask he's also been in his clown
makeup the entire time just like Arthur
Fleck
I believe whatever doesn't kill you
simply makes
straining chair one of the most
interesting things about Joker's final
trailer and the first one is what we
don't see even though we know to expect
a bloody violent movie we've seen almost
no violence at all in the trailers at
least no violence from Joker himself
we've seen him get punched by Thomas
Wayne whacked with his own sign and
beaten up by jerks on the subway we've
seen his followers clash with the cops
but we have yet to see Joker himself
attack anyone
the only possible exception is a shot
toward the end of the final trailer when
Fleck appears to be stomping on
something in an alley but it isn't clear
if he's attacking a person or just
stomping out of frustration either seems
likely and yet one of the most memorable
images from the trailer looks like it
comes right after Joker committed
homicide as the newspaper headline
suggests we see him in a bathroom
cleaning himself up at one point he
dances slowly and we see what appears to
be smeared blood on his chin for a
character historically defined by
violence we've seen almost none of it's
in these trailers saving flecks rage for
the big screen is a savvy move and we'll
know the full extent of it when Joker
hits theaters on October 4 check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book characters are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]